ومن غبائهم سقطت الجوهرة السوداء
من ايديهم. ونقصد القارة
الافريقية. نعم قارة باكملها
تسقط من اليد الفرنسية كانت سلة
مليئة بالثروات وغنية
باليورانيوم وذهبت بعيدا.
الفرنسيون تلك الزاوية يندبون
حظهم. لكن مهلا فها هي اليوم
فرنسا بكلها تسقط من يد رئيسها
ماكرون. عن اي ازمة نتحدث. فجر
ماكرون قنبلة سياسية زعزعة
الشارع الفرنسي. فخرج الشعب عن
بكرة ابيه الى الساحات
والميادين. تحولت عاصمة الجمال
والعطور لمكب نفايات مقرفة.
حاولت باريس اسقاط الاقتصاد
الروسي. فردت موسكو بهجمة مرتدة
ليذهب الفرنسيون في مهب عن مذبحة
الاقتصاد الفرنسي نتحدث وللقصة
بقية. بعد ان كانت فرنسا هي
القدر المحكوم لافريقيا او على
الاقل جزءا مهما من التاريخ
الافريقي بحثت القارة السمراء عن
حقوقها في السيادة وتقرير المصير
والتمتع بالخيرات الطبيعية بحرية
دون ضغط او تدخل. علاقات فرنسا
بافريقيا محكومة بثوابت تعود
لجذورها الاستعمارية وسياساتها
التوسعية على الرغم من زعماء
الفرنسيين من كل اطياف اللون
السياسي. لكن سياسة الاستعمار هي
الصفة السائدة للحكومات
المتعاقبة. لنأتي لكم بما هو
اكبر. فحتى وقت قريب كانت فرنسا
تسقط رؤساء افارقة وتنصب غيرهم
بحسب ارادتها دون احترام حقوق
الافارقة في تقرير مصيرهم. وكانت
باريس مسؤولة في حالات كثيرة عن
نشوب حروب اهلية شردت الاف
المواطنين وهجرتهم من ديارهم.
واعادت رسم الحدود والكيان دون
رحمة في القارة السمراء. ومع كل
تلك الاحداث كان من الطبيعي ان
تخسر فرنسا كل شيء في افريقيا.
وهي منذ سنوات تنسحب تدريجيا. او
دعونا نقول ان الفرنسيين يطردون
من الجنة الافريقية وبشكل مهين.
ويحل مكانهم الدب الروسي وكذلك
التنين الصيني. لكن موسكو اصبحت
الشريك الامني الاول للافارقة
وبكين هي الشريك التجاري الاقوى.
لكن الشركاء الجدد وفقا لعقود
فقد ولى زمن الاستعمار. الشوارع
الفرنسية تشتعل. دوامة الخروج من
افريقيا شكلت ازمة صعبة لفرنسا.
لكن الازمة الحقيقة كانت في
الداخل الفرنسي. فنقابة القطارات
اضربت عن العمل. الطوابير
الطويلة من السيارات التي تنتظر
دورها للحصول على بعض من الوقود.
شركات الطيران الفرنسية طالبت
الشركات العالمية بتخفيف الرحلات
الى المطارات الفرنسية.
المظاهرات تزداد بوتيرة مخيفة.
وها هم المتظاهرون يقطعون الطريق
الى المطارات. ومطار شارل ديجول
خير دليل. ليس ذلك فحسب. هنا
المديرية العامة للطيران الفرنسي
المدني تأمر بالغاء ثلث الرحلات
الجوية في مطار اورلي بالعاصمة.
تم تخفيض عدد الرحلات التي
تقدمها مطارات ليون ومارسيليا
وتولوز بنسبة عشرين في المائة.
لتوجه سلطات المطارات تحذيرا
للركاب من احتمال حدوث انتهاكات
اخرى. ومن كان معه رحلة سفر حتى
اشعار اخر. ونحن نتحدث هنا عن
فرنسا من كانت قبلة للسياح من
اصداع الارض. فيا لها من ازمة
اعادت احفاد نابليون عقودا الى
الوراء. لكن مهلا فالى حد هذه
اللحظة كل شيء طبيعي وما جرى في
فرنسا يجري في اوروبا برمتها.
بعد ان قطعت عنهم روسيا شريان
الطاقة. ليرمي الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون قنبلة سياسية
غير موقوتة يصفها المراقبون
بانها قنبلة نووية للسياسة
الفرنسية. انفجرت حال اطلاق
ماكرون لها. ماكرون ارتكب خطأ
فادحا قد يطيح به من سدة الحكم.
نعم ونقصد تعديل رفع سن التقاعد.
وعلى الفرنسيين ان يعملوا لسنوات
اخرى تصل لاربع سنوات بعد سن
الستين. ضج الشعب. اشتعلت
المظاهرات امتلأت الشوارع. عمت
الفوضى. لن يقبل الفرنسيون بهذا
القرار. ليتلقى الشعب جرعة امل
مؤقتة. استبشر بها خيرا مع ان
البرلمان الفرنسي لن يقبل بهذا
القانون. كان لماكرون رأي اخر
حيث مرر القرار دون العودة
للبرلمان معتمدا على المادة تسعة
واربعين في الدستور الفرنسي. جن
جنون الشعب ومعهم ضج البرلمان
فكان استقبالهم جنوني لرئيس
الوزراء تحت قبة البرلمان برفع
اللافتات وانشاد الاهازيج. انه
احد اعظم الاستقبالات لحكومة في
مجلس للنواب في العالم اجمع. هنا
خرجت صحيفة التايم الامريكية عن
توجه البرلمان لسحب الثقة من
الحكومة الفرنسية. وماكرون قاب
قوسين او ادنى من ترك منصبه ان
لم يجد حلا لهذه المشكلة. نعم.
قرار التقاعد هذا قرار تاريخي
فرنسي. بدأه الرئيس المعين في
تسعينيات القرن الماضي جاك
شيراك. وانتهى به الامر بحل
الحكومة وترك السلطة. ومن بعده
جاء ساركوزي وكان قرار التقاعد
احد اهم الاسباب لسقوطه وحكومته
معا. نعم انه قرار واحد قد يترك
ماكرون بعيدا عن السلطة. وبعد ان
كان يحلم برئاسة اوروبا كلها
وانشاء جيش اوروبي تحت اشرافه
وقيادته. ها هو اليوم يبحث عمن
ينقذ كرسيه من الشعب الغاضب.
فلنتجه قليلا نحو عاصمة السحر
والجمال التي جعلت العطر الفرنسي
يفوح في ارجاء العالم. بلاد
العطور تفوح منها اليوم الروائح
النتنة. عمال النظافة في باريس
يواصلون اضرابهم احتجاجا على
قرار رفع سن التقاعد لتتحول
العاصمة الفرنسية الى مكب
للنفايات والاف الاطنان من
القمائم تتراكم في كل مكان. ويا
لها من مشاهد مقززة. لتدخل
العاصمة الفرنسية وما عدة مدن
فرنسية اخرى اضرابات. اغلاقات
احتجاجات حاشدة بخروج اكثر من
مليون فرنسي تحت ما سمي الخميس
الاسود. رافضين لقانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد. لكن الرئيس
الفرنسي يصر على تمرير قرار
التقاعد كل الاحتجاجات. فهل
اقتربت نهاية سلطته? ها هو
ماكرون يجيب لن نرضخ للعنف. اشجب
العنف باقصى درجات القوة. هناك
في باريس وفي مدن اخرى عديدة في
انحاء البلاد. عملت فرق التنظيف
وسط زجاج مكسور وصلت به قمامة
متفحمة ومحطات حافلات محطمة. بعد
اشتباكات عنيفة جرت بين محتجين
والشرطة. اصيب بها نحو اربعمائة
وواحد واربعين ضابط شرطة واعتقل
اربعمائة وخمسة وسبعين شخصا.
واصيب عشرات المتظاهرين. بلاد
الثورات تعاني من الفوضى يا سادة
وتعج بالاضطرابات. الدب الروسي
يأكل الديك الفرنسي. انتعاش
اقتصادي قوي بعد تداعيات جائحة
كورونا. لكن هذا الانتعاش لم يدم
طويلا. لتتعرض فرنسا لصدمة طاقة
مدفوعة بغزو روسيا لاوكرانيا.
ارتفع التضخم تباطأ النشاط
الاقتصادي. باريس اعلنت مواجهة
موسكو بدعم اوكرانيا وفرض
العقوبات على الروس. عندما توقع
وزير الاقتصاد الفرنسي برونو
لومير انهيار الاقتصاد الروسي
نجح اقتصاد موسكو وسقط الاقتصاد
الفرنسي. وبعد قطع شريان الطاقة
من الجانب الروسي. ها هي ستون
مليار يورو هي التكلفة الاضافية
للطاقة قياسا بتكلفتها العام
الماضي قبل الحرب الاوكرانية
الروسية. بما يشكل اثنين ونصف في
المائة من الناتج المحلي. في اول
صدمة خارجية تاريخية منذ العام
الف وتسعمائة واربعة وسبعين.
بدلا من معاقبة روسيا عادت
العقوبات على الاوروبيين وفي
مقدمتهم فرنسا. وهذا ما جنته
ايديهم بانفسهم. فها هو النائب
الفرنسي تييري مارياني يصرح بان
الانصياع لمطالب زيلنسكي سيؤدي
الى انهيار الاقتصاد الاوروبي.
وعلى المدى الطويل ستضطر البلدان
الاكثر استقرارا ماليا لاصلاح
الاتحاد او تركه. الازمة لم
تنتهي بعد. الفرنسيون بحشودهم
الغفيرة يرددون هتافات لا ولا
دبابات ولا صواريخ لاوكرانيا.
ولنخرج من الناتو وماكرون لا
نريد حربكم. ولا للحرب العالمية
الثالثة ليعمل بعضهم على تمزيق
علم حلف الناتو. ويا لها من ضربة
لاقوى حلف دفاعي في العالم ان
انفصلت عنه فرنسا مرة اخرى.
استعمروا دول افريقيا لعقود.
عاثوا فيها فسادا. نفذ صبر
الافارقة وطردوا الاستعمار بعد
عقود من الظلم. وبعد ان اعلنت
باريس على موسكو بالعقوبات عادت
عليهم العقوبات بنتيجة عكسية.
فهل استجيبت دعوة المظلومين وحان
وقت